ever since the fbi raid on donald
trump's home in florida a couple of
weeks ago we've been following the right
wings attempt to throw everything at the
wall and see what sticks as it pertains
to excuses for the former president and
they really have tried everything right
they've tried saying that the fbi
planted evidence they tried saying that
trump was cooperating so you didn't have
to do this they tried saying that this
is just not how you treat a former
president and this is a political witch
hunt all of these different excuses
right but now we've got a new one and it
comes to us from
rudy giuliani who as we know is facing
enough problems right now because he is
the target of that election fraud
lawsuit in georgia rudy went on newsmax
and made the case that it was totally
fine that donald trump had those
documents with him down in mar-a-lago
locked away in the basement because they
were just as safe there as they would
have been at a government facility and
that's exactly why
he should be able to get away with this
without any consequences let's take a
look at the video of rudy making a fool
of himself
and and now
they want to make him responsible for
having taken classified documents
and preserved them really if you look at
the espionage act it's not really about
taking the documents
it's about destroying them or hiding
them
or giving them to the enemy right it's
not about taking them and putting them
in a place
that's roughly as safe as they were in
the first place well to be fair to rudy
giuliani when hillary clinton's email
scandal was in focus he was actually
saying the exact same thing like he
would go on tv and he would talk about
how the emails stored on a private
server those are roughly as safe as they
would be if stored through the proper
channels of the government oh wait no he
actually he didn't say those things
funny how there's a double standard
between donald trump and hillary clinton
on this issue but what's funny about
this clip is that rudy actually debunks
himself in real time because he says
that if you look at the espionage act
it's not about taking documents it's
about hiding them destroying them or
giving them to the enemy well what
exactly is donald trump being
investigating for if not for hiding the
documents he brought them to mar-a-lago
and he hid them in the basement uh so
definitely debunking his own argument
there is rudy giuliani and then we also
know that trump liked to destroy
documents we've heard stories about him
ripping up documents we've seen the
pictures of him flushing the documents
supposedly 10 to 15 times and even
eating a document as omarosa alleges but
rudy manages in this clip to be wrong
about something else too which is pretty
impressive because there was only a 30
second clip that i showed you um which
is that he was wrong about the espionage
act and what it says let's take a look
at the espionage act it says whoever
lawfully having possession of access to
control over or being entrusted with any
document writing code book signal book
sketch photograph photographic negative
blueprint plan map model instrument
appliance or note relating to the
national defense or information relating
to the national defense which
information the possessor has reason to
believe could be used to the injury of
the united states or to the advantage of
any foreign nation willfully
communicates delivers transmits or
causes to be communicated delivered or
transmitted or attempts to communicate
deliver transmit or cause to be
communicated delivered or transmitted
the same to any person not entitled to
receive it or willfully retains the same
and fails to deliver it on demand to the
officer or employee of the united states
entitled to receive it okay so that's
some impressively verbose legal jargon
there but if you cut through the fat you
see possession of access to or control
over defense information and then also
being unwilling to hand it over to the
proper authorities who are entitled to
it that's a violation of the espionage
act so rudy would have been better
served to read the law that he was
talking about before going on newsmax
and spewing nonsense about it on their
airwaves and then finally how are we to
believe that these documents were safer
than they would have been than at a
government facility or just as safe
because why they had a lock on them in
the basement at mar-a-lago is that the
argument you want to make so the
staffers at mar-a-lago the maintenance
people the custodians they could
probably get at least around that area
you best believe they don't have
security clearances so how is that in
any proper way the proper handling of
documents it's clearly not and then
we've also heard about how nonchalant
trump was when it pertained to sensitive
information at mar-a-lago while he was
president even making an impromptu
situation room on the patio at
mar-a-lago after north korea tested a
missile launch with guests of the resort
just walking by able to see exactly what
was being talked about between the
president and his team and remember
shinzo abe the late former japanese
prime minister was also there he must
have been absolutely shocked by the
entire thing so all the excuses from the
right for trump on this have been bad
they seem to be getting worse actually
we may at some point have to drop a
formal list of all of the horrible
excuses and rank them from best to worst
and my prediction is that this latest
one from rudy giuliani that the
documents were roughly as safe as they
would have been in a government facility
that has to be pretty high on the list
all right we're going to go to a break
now but we'll be back with much more of
the david pakman show right after this